hey friends welcome today i just want to
share with you a story that i found
really really insightful and
it made me think a lot
this story illustrates very well this
concept of life being a single player
game which is a statement shared by
naval ravikant this story made me
understand better and from a different
and new angle this concept of life being
a single player game i found this story
from a tweet
of the renowned investor jim oshangi to
naval street life is a single player
game now i will recite the words of jim
from his twitter post this story
concerns a man who comes to the door of
the law
seeking admittance
the guard there refuses to allow him to
pass the door
but says if the man waits long enough
someday in the uncertain future he might
gain admittance the man grows older
and tries to bribe the guard who takes
it
but does not allow him to enter
the man ends up selling everything he
owns
gives it to the guard as a bride which
the guard also takes
but still refuses to allow the man to
enter and says i'm only taking this
bribe
so you do not abandon all hope finally
the man is old ill and about to die
but masters the strength to confront the
guard
and say i've been told that the law
exists for all
why then has nobody else come here
seeking admittance
the guard responds
this door has been made only for you
and now i'm going to close it forever
he then slams the door and the man dies
so your tweet about life being a single
pair game
made me think about this and how to make
sense of it
in my idea
the door in the story is an analog for
the gateless gate in
san and the guard is a metaphor for
consensus reality to which the man
obviously adheres
after chasing entry to the door his
entire life
he never even considered that the whole
time
he was asking permission of the guard
the door itself was wide open and he
could walk through it at any time
only without
asking permission of the guard
consensus reality and since it was only
meant for him
it closes at his death
so what
my idea which your tweet sparked
is a seeker of truth
can never gain enlightenment from
another or ask permission of another or
bribe another or ask another to
enlighten
him or her
because that's something that cannot be
given by another
it can only be earned by the seeker
themselves
the door was always open until the time
of the man's death at which time
the door was closed and locked forever
the man was looking for instructions
for prescriptions on 10 ways to walk
through the door of justice he was
seeking a weigh-in but asking all the
wrong questions he was stopped by his
own reality tunnel belief system
that told him he must follow the rules
of social convention perforce of others
to get through the door
when if he realizes that life is a
single-player game he would have ignored
by failing to understand that life is a
single-player game he adhered to game
rules or social conventions and beliefs
which forever blocked him from going
through the open door
because he conflated consensus reality
with his own reality leading him to all
the grown paths
you must simply walk through it
the door of the law
or the gateless gate
on your own
this story appears at the end of the
book the trial which was written by
franz kafka now two quotes that comes to
my mind when thinking about this story
you enter the forest at the darkest
point where there is no path
where there is a way or path
is someone else's path
you are not on your own path if you
follow someone else's way
you are not going to realize your full
potential by joseph campbell judge man
by his questions not his answers
voltaire and now i leave you with some
words from kapil gupta and navarro kant
who also shed some light on this matter
if you want to be the best in the world
at anything you cannot follow
prescription if you want to be okay at
it then sure you can follow a
prescription if you want to learn how to
lose a pound a month and get in decent
shape then you can follow a calorie
counting worksheet but if you want to be
a shredded bodybuilder or an olympic
athlete you're not going to get there
through how-to's you're going to have to
create and forge your own path that is
unique to you
would that be a good way of putting it
well what i will add to that is that
one does not have to want to become
the greatest in the world
if you look at the lives of human beings
there is intense struggle the guy who
works three jobs doesn't want to work
three jobs he may not want to become
tiger woods but he wants to be beyond
being forced to work three jobs
what keeps him working three jobs is
prescriptions
the futility of prescriptions
does not just
harm one who wants to become world class
it gravely harms the one who simply
doesn't want to struggle the way i think
about it in the business world is that
hard work has very little to do with
effectiveness
the grocery store owner or the person
working at a restaurant might work 60 80
hours a week and that might be all elon
musk is working but elon's making a lot
more money because of his specific
knowledge knowledge that cannot be
taught but can be learned on the job if
you have a strong enough desire because
elon is doing the right things he is far
more effective in earning power and the
right things at least in business can't
be taught because it's a moving target
it can only give very vague principles
that inspire people to head in the right
direction but i can't teach you how to
make money or trade the stock market
it's like when people ask you for stock
tips
no one who's any good at stock trading
gives actionable investment advice in a
public forum because all the details are
too hard to convey i can always tell
people who ask for stock tips they're
not really serious about investing
people who ask for book recommendations
aren't really serious about reading
people who ask what business should i
build aren't really serious about
entrepreneurship
people who say what career path should i
take they're not really serious about
their career when someone's asking for a
how-to and anything they aren't actually
that serious about it if they were truly
serious about it they would figure it
out but then that leaves the paradoxical
question well how do i figure it out
take the person who quote made it and
became world class in whatever he did
if he went back and retraced his steps
and did everything again
the same way
but this time he did it by mimicking
himself he would fail
even he wouldn't be able to do it
what has to be understood
is that where greatness comes from
it's a very murky affair
it is non-linear
it is unpredictable perhaps nature and
the universe set it up this way
that
you have to jump in
and once you jump in the soup
and you're being bombarded through all
sides and you live in confusion and you
have no idea which way is up
if the obsession is there
then what happens is through some
messy process
you find a way you see light at the end
of the tunnel you forge a path through
the jungle
that was not done according to a how you
were flailing the entire time
so there was no how to flail
when you come out through the tunnel and
someone asks you how you did it you have
no idea the thing that's almost
laughable is when you ask a great
athlete can you show me how you did that
they won't come out and say i have no
idea
they will provide you with some
semblance of an answer which is a
non-answer and what they will do is
because there's a gun point to their
head and their backs against a wall
they will create the highlights
when the human being who watches that
follows the highlights he misses and the
reason that he misses is because it's
all the small things
i can't watch roger federer play tennis
and swing the racket the same way
nor will any description from him on how
to swing the rocket get me to swing it
the right way then we go to intellectual
efforts we start asking warren buffett
why he invests in the company and there
he can try and create a mental construct
as to how he thinks and how he invests
in the company but there are just as
many details to warren buffett's
activities when he decides what to
invest in and how he lives his life and
how he thinks as there are to roger
federer's body running around a tennis
court hitting a ball the details are not
transmissible they're not copyable you
can be inspired
to try it yourself but without that
sincerity that obsession you won't get
there
not only are the details not
transmissible the detail's not even
knowable
ah so warren and roger don't even know
it themselves absolutely not no great
artist knows the things that you do
greatest are the things that you know
not how you do them i would argue that
you're not even there when you do them
you're not consciously thinking about it
i find that when i'm speaking i do best
when i'm not thinking about what i'm
going to say and i don't even hear what
i'm going to say until it comes out of
my mouth finally my takeaways are the
following
be conscious of what is truly real
do not mix objective reality with the
social convention rules
forge your own path rather than keep
asking others on how to do things
forever and if there is sufficient
obsession you will find a way
thank you
you